le bois de la discorde mardi en
bourgogne ventes annulées ce mercredi un
collectif réitère son appel au boycott
de la vente organisée par l'office
national des forêts à lamotte beuvron
aujourd'hui ce collectif d'exploitants
forestiers exportateurs conteste le
décret paru samedi au journal officiel
décret qui limite la vente du chêne à la
seule zone européenne pour protéger les
scieries françaises
le commerce mondial est quelque chose de
nécessaire
il est vital pour la survie pour les
sociétés pour les entreprises et il ya
des qualités bois que nous sommes qu'ils
ne peuvent pas accepter dans des raisons
de coût de que nous comprenons tout à
fait est que nous mettons forcément dans
ce qui est aujourd'hui le marché à
l'export que nous avons tous plus ou
moins été obligé de créer et entretenir
finalement la vente par appel d'offres a
bien eu lieu c'était l'intérêt de
certains exploitants et des scieries qui
disent subir une dérégulation du marché
des régulations à l'origine du décret
protectionniste du gouvernement soutenu
par une partie de la filière qui a été
constaté depuis plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années
c'est qu'une bonne partie des bois
exploité en france dans les forêts
françaises quittent le territoire sans
être transformée et plus
particulièrement le chêne notamment qui
part dans des contenaires directement
pour la chine et donc ça veut dire que
la valeur ajoutée sur ces bois là ne se
fait pas chez nous mais se fait là-bas
et les emplois ne se font pas ici le
premier phénomène ce que la demande de
la part de la chine et à de très
importants et donc les possibilités de
transformation en chine
de par les coûts sociaux enfin c'est pas
ben la peine de faire un grand discours
à ce sujet ont subi les mêmes
conséquences que je pense pas mal de
métier la transformation en chine et
c'est certainement plus faible que la
transformation en france et donc leurs
possibilités d'achats de matières
premières est supérieur au nôtre
par conséquent ce mercredi l'équivalent
de 6 millions d'euros de bois été mis
sur le marché par celle de chaînes sur
pied en majorité du centre val de loire
des dizaines d'acheteurs de toute la
france ne voulait pas faire l'impasse
sur cette vente par conviction ou par
nécessité